Уперше за 5 місяців на посаді новий президент України
спілкується з журналістами. Володимир Зеленський,
який ламає усталені шаблони в українській політиці,
вирішив замість традиційної прес-конференції
влаштувати фудмарафон,
тож замість офіціозної зали - сучасний лофт,
черг до мікрофону немає, а всюди смачна їжа та безліч напоїв.
В Офісі президента Зеленського пояснили, що
обрали цей великий фудмаркет лише тому, що тут
може вміститися одночасно велика кількість людей
і президент Зеленський хоче працювати з пресою
фактично до 9-ї години вечора.
Його завдання - відповісти на запитання майже 300 журналістів.
І це ще не всі бажаючі, їх обрали з понад
1000 представників ЗМІ, які напередодні встигли
подати заявку на участь у давно очікуваній
першій зустрічі медіаспільноти й нового президента.
300 журналістів поділили на групи по 7-10 осіб,
кожній групі виділили на спілкування по півгодини.
Те, що цей формат взаємодії з пресою -
своєрідне ноу-хау в Україні, президенту подобається.
- Відкритий формат, готовий спілкуватися, незаготовлені питання.
Найпопулярніші запитання від західних ЗМІ -
про розмову Зеленського з президентом США Трампом.
Приміром, про розслідування фірми "Бурісма"
та ролі в її діяльності сина американського ексвіцепрезидента Джо Байдена.
- Я сказав, що я готовий, готовий розглядати
цю історію, цей кейс, якщо це...
будь ласка, запрошуйте вашого генерального прокурора,
з'єднуйте з нашим, аде згідно з законодавством.
Згідно з міжнародними відносинами. Будь ласка, я не проти.
Ми не хочемо ховати будь-які справи.
Ми не хочемо ховати будь-які справи,
ми відкриті.
Не менш "гаряча" тема - формула Штайнмаєра
або формула Зеленського щодо врегулювання
ситуації на Донбасі. Українські та іноземні ЗМІ
хочуть роз’яснень від президента.
- Чому Вам не звернутися до Штайнмайєра
з проханням приїхати в країну і пояснити вашим критикам
про свій план про врегулювання ситуації на Донбасі,
так звану формулу Штайнмаєра?
Він - потужна людина. І я гадаю, я так думаю
я їх не знаю внутрі, але я думаю, що він саме на нашій стороні.
Так, може, йому приїхати в Україну?
Я боюсь, якщо він прийде, це буде мій вплив
на бувшу владу і я не хочу цього робити.
Мені достатньо, я навіть його не просив щось говорити.
Я його не просив коментувати.
Я думаю, що вони самі були в шоці, що 5 років,
про що вони говорили, перекреслено якимись політичними закликами.
А співгромадянам, які тепер називають
формулу Штаймаєйра капітуляцією перед Росією
і створюють штаби спротиву цій капітуляції,
президент відповів так.
- Це їх вибір. Вони можуть робити.
Але я гадаю, що вони зараз підривають.
Хтось із них просто не знає, що відбувається,
чи хтось не хоче слухати. Усі повинні розуміти
перед тим, що вони роблять крок назад.
Це не крок до припинення війни.
Я думаю, що це неправильно.
Стосунки України з ЄС нині на стадії
перевантаження, це Зеленський частково визнає.
Принаймні, він став першим президентом України,
який заявив про недостатню допомогу Україні
з боку Німеччини та Франції. Та чи хоче він
вибачитися перед, наприклад, канцлеркою Анґелою Меркель?
- Моя риторика була такою.
Я не хотів нікого образити. Я сказав те, що думаю.
Я завжди так роблю – говорю те, що я думаю.
Я не хотів нікого образити. Так чи інакше,
я дуже їм вдячний і вони знають, що напередодні
вони там повертали Росію в ПАРЄ,
продовжували "Північний потік-2".
Я з ними дуже багато говорив про це.
Вони теж сказали позицію своєї країни, тому що
вони захищають свою країну, свій бізнес,
і ця позиція не влаштовує мене як президента
і не влаштовує політику України. Тому вони мені там
чесно казали, а я тут теж казав чесно.
Не усі журналісти задоволені таким форматом
спілкування з президентом. Часу замало.
Поставити уточнювальні питання неможливо.
Доводиться перебивати один одного.
Мені дуже подобається формат. Що люди можуть зайти, поїсти, послухати президента...
Чи ми погоджуємся з тим, що президент
проводить пресконференції для представників ЗМІ
- четвертої влади, -
проводить прийомний день на ринку.
Чи це нормально? Якщо це нормально,
то, в принципі, формат ок.
От зараз йому бургери піднесли…
Водночас багато журналістів вважають цей прийом
на фудкорті все ж позитивною подією.
На зміну ухильним відповідям
політиків минулих років прийшли плутані,
але, здається, щирі видповіді молодого президента.
Багатослівні заяви Зеленського -
величезний матеріал для журналістських перевірок і аналізу.
А те, що він узагалі зустрівся з пресою,
нехай і в такому форматі, показує: ймовірно,
в Офісі президента зрозуміли, що пряме спілкування
Зеленського з народом через соцмережі,
оминаючи критично налаштовану пресу, -
не єдиний варіант комунікації з суспільством.